So today,
today is the day.
It's been said before that being an
editor is a thankless job because when
you do it right,
no one is supposed to notice.
I think this idea goes for Casey
Neistat's daily Vlog 100 percent.
When Neistat succeeds,
all you should see is the fun.
No,
there are plenty of imitators.
I think it's pretty much impossible to
duplicate the style of Casey Neistat.
I think that style is worth taking a
closer look at because along with
various other interesting sub genres
like what we're trying to do with video
essays,
the daily Vlog,
particularly what Neistat has done to
it,
has grown organically and uniquely out
of the medium where it lives.
Online.
Video shouldn't let people do that.
The inner vitality of Neistat show is
undeniable.
That's down to his personality.
His worldview is insane.
Work Ethic,
even his recklessness,
but I think the craft that supports
these things goes largely unnoticed.
See,
Neistat's revolutionary move was
bringing more than a decade of
videographic experience to a sub genre
that prizes amateur craft daily Vlogs
need a dose or a feeling of amateurism
because what makes them valuable is how
real they seem than an age where reality
TV was dominated by Jersey shore and the
hills were scenes were prompted by the
suggestions of producers,
if not completely scripted,
I don't care about anything else,
but me and Gianni smushing.
Daily vlogs are the response or real
slice of life with no corporate mediator
and the signature of something that's
not corporate is a lack of Polish
product that passes through the hands of
only one person before it was delivered
to an audience.
No audio touchups,
no color correction,
no notes from a distance boardroom.
Nice.
That elevated that amateur spirit to an
art,
and I say spirit because I think of what
he does is actually amateurish when it
comes to his vlog on Youtube in general,
was trying to find opportunities to up
my game.
When it comes to production.
Value Neistat has been slowly developing
his style from the start in 2003.
He and his brother made a short film
called ipod dirty secret about the
crappiness of Ipod batteries that
collected over a million views in six
weeks in the era before youtube,
hybrid combination of Gonzo journalism,
guerrilla filmmaking and cinema verite.
This signature evolved across a number
of short movies and eventually found its
way into the Vlog for which it's a
perfect match and cinema verite.
The camera is often acknowledged,
made a part of the product.
Neistat takes this to another level by
making his massive collection of camera
equipment and the studio,
another character in his show,
dslrs,
gopros power shots,
three sixties,
iphones,
drones,
each camera and each lens has its own
personality and Neistat's constantly
swapping them around,
but it goes further than this nice that
keeps all his old footage routinely
working in mini dv memories,
vhs tapes,
and other first generation video camera
clips within this universe.
Old Video camera footage doesn't look
dated.
It's just another strata and the ongoing
story of the democratization of
filmmaking story that parallels our
lives.
His main rig,
however,
is this a Canon Seventy d on a gorilla
pod.
I mean,
this tells you everything you need to
know about neistat stat as a filmmaker,
this is a heavy thing to carry all day
daily vloggers before this may do with
handheld,
so varying sizes,
powershot small enough to fit in your
pocket.
The idea was that it was always with you
on obtrusive.
Neistat has a slightly different emo.
He wants to show to feel natural,
not be natural.
My goal with this blog isn't,
and it has never been to like share all
the intimacies of my life.
It's always just been to create a good
or entertaining piece of content every
day and so to up his production value
takes a million little things like
setting a camera down,
framing a shot,
then running back out of frame to come
into frame again,
like the shot I showed at the beginning
of this video,
like going out at sunset and waiting 30
minutes.
Well,
three different cameras take three
different timelapses like carrying a 70
d on a gorilla pot all day,
like carrying a 70 d and a gorilla pod
and a boosted board controller all in
the same hand.
Just to look natural.
I'm trying to eat sean,
how to ride the boosted board record
with a video camera and drink a smoothie
at the same time.
How's it going,
John?
The effortlessness of Casey Neistat's.
Flog is an illusion.
The next time you watch one,
just pay more attention to his camera
setups.
Notice how things are framed.
Notice how his timelapses always feature
some sort of large movement.
Notice how edits through action feels so
smooth,
and then think about what actually was
happening there.
There are a lot of things on youtube,
but only a few of them are legitimately
something new under the sun.
These new styles cultivated not from
film or TV,
but out of how we watch and share
specifically online video,
have to be acknowledged and studied and
celebrate it.
If we want this medium to be recognized
as something other than the stepchild of
older formats,
I get a thrill watching Neistat's work.
I'm motivated by it,
by the art that's in it,
and how wonderfully visible it can be.
It's a style you can't duplicate because
the show is animated and held together
by his energy,
but that ought to be encouraging because
it means that in the age of online
video,
when a creation can be the unmediated
vision of its creator,
there's the style within all of us and
there are millions of people waiting for
you to find it.
Yes,
I'm starting a proper daily blog.
I'm site.
There is a new nerdwriter video every
Wednesday,
so if you go right there and click that,
you'll subscribe and get all the videos
and that really helps me out.
Um,
I want to tell you guys about a channel
that I really love called wisecrack.
They do shows like eight bit philosophy,
earthlings,
cinema,
thug notes,
which is my favorite probably.
You can go right there and watch a
video.
Subscribe if you like it.
You like the nerd writer,
you're going to like them.
So they're awesome.
Check that out.
I'll see you guys all next Wednesday for
something new.
Oh,
and by the way.